hello folks
welcome to rational science
uh the only site on the internet that
does
physics for real yesterday i came back
from
iceland nice trip i
celebrated my 45th honeymoon
long time uh never go to iceland uh
it's too cold too windy too rainy too
expensive don't ever make that mistake
okay anyways uh we're gonna be doing a
little bit
of extinction first then we're going to
do into
go into the lecture that we have today
which is on
whether the electron in fact essentially
the entire atom whether any of that
belongs to
geometry in other words are any of those
do any of those qualify as geometric
figures okay and then i'll get into the
questions and comments that people made
for the last uh three weeks i'd say at
least i have been able to give my
lecture
okay let's go with extinction let's
start here fellow says
he went to this site he um tells me
asked me to go to the site to this
youtube video
i think it was a youtube video and the
fellow
there uh he says the file he
goes through the whole extinction uh
thing of what happened at the kt
extinction which is the
cretaceous tertiary extinction which
is a 65 million years ago roughly
and that's when the dinosaurs died and
mammals
expanded so this fellow uh in the uh
video says the following says one of the
statements he makes he says
even if there were no asteroids a lot of
dinosaurs
and marine life would probably be gone
anyway well he never explained why he
thinks that is the case
in fact when you when you listen to the
uh video
this is what you see he just goes in
there and
re regurgitates the party line he starts
out by saying that the
uh asteroid is the number one theory
then there could be
climate change for different reasons uh
maybe volcanoes that
uh deccan traps in india and
maybe you know um there was uh
uh climate change or maybe uh in this
case marine
regression you know the ocean levels
dropped
so what should you conclude well you
should conclude that these people keep
telling you the same story over and over
for the last 50 years they have
no different theory if you want to have
a different theory
you have to come here there is no other
place for a different theory
what's the theory here the theory here
is that
the economy collapsed the dinosaurs
economy collapsed and people don't
always understand what
what that really means means that we are
animals
we are humans are animals just like the
dinosaurs were animals amphibians were
animals all these were animals
okay people think that we're not animals
and that we're kind of different and
we're gonna die
a different death than the animals in
the past because we have something
called
intelligence we have developed this
extraordinary
intelligence and that saves us from all
faiths
i can only give you my five cents worth
that five cents worth is that
um mother nature kills
through the vitals what i call the
vitals
and the vitals are not trade not
commerce
not money um
you know not all animals have money not
all animals trade not all
animals engage in commerce all animals
have some things in common they
typically breathe they typically drink
water or some kind of liquid
and they typically eat something where
they sometimes get their liquids from
so that's how that's uh universal
another
universal could be that they all have
children they all have
they all sleep okay so we have some
things in common
with all the other animals in the animal
kingdom
and so the question is does mother
nature kill through
money well not specifically not
specifically other animals don't have
money
so she goes through the vitals now one
vital could be you know having fewer
children
you know she stops she stops the species
from having children
and when that happens um
you know what we call a background
extinction
yeah the species can go extinct
however you know in the case of humans
we
we're probably not going to die through
a what what i call a background
extinction in other words where
only us we disappear and the rest of the
world
continues rolling like if nothing no no
that ain't gonna happen
when we die everyone dies we're gonna
take everyone with us
and that's known as a mass extinction so
we're gonna die in a mass extinction
and for that we need to go back to the
dinosaurs and figure out how
they died how the amphibians died how
the archosaurs died
how the mammal reptiles died in the
permian and so on we got to go through
different ages and figure out
what happened to them and see if
whatever killed them is going to kill us
and whether we have any
antidote to whatever killed them is
intelligence is technology is the fact
that we can foresee events
does that does any of that help us avoid
extinction or avoid the mechanism that
killed all the other animals
that's that's the reasoning here okay
and so we go back and we find out that
yeah that
maybe they were killed through one of
the vitals maybe
they lack sleep i don't think so
i think it wasn't an issue of sleep
could it be
that maybe uh they ran out of air
well it could have happened maybe there
was a climate change a sudden climate
change no air and they all died yeah
great uh i don't think that happened
either
no i think it goes down to uh liquids
water and uh food okay so um
that's more likely and what do i mean by
that well
if the food disappears for sure the
food that the dinosaurs ate disappears
the herbivores will disappear and then
followed by the
carnivores okay so that's the idea here
and the same thing can happen to us food
can disappear
and you say well how can that possibly
be we have trade we produce all the food
we want we're all fat
uh well it can disappear because we only
produce
food for money for profits the day that
uh money is no more that we don't
believe in money and
you know in god we don't trust anymore
then that's uh
when money is no more uh we don't
produce
anymore because we only produce because
of money
or distribute because of money and so i
think that's
it's going to be the same mechanism in
the case of men it's just going to be
through commerce through trade but
the mechanism is the same we run out of
food
it's food that's going to kill us okay
and that's what killed the animals in
the past
that's the theory we propose here so uh
you know um this notion that climate
change does anything to us that peak oil
that disease some kind of disease kills
us that there's a volcano
that's gonna kill us that there are
asteroids and comets that are going to
come and hit us
uh i don't think so none of those will
ever happen mother nature doesn't do
extinction
mass extinctions in such a way she does
it through the vitals
primarily food and water or liquids
okay so that's the distinction here
okay another fellow brings up an issue
he says why would you think
that in an age where people are getting
fatter and fatter
the world will be out of food soon well
again it's got to do with economics
falling apart and we produce food only
because of economics
because of trade because of commerce
because of money okay for profits that's
why we produce food and distribute food
if we were to wipe out money for
whatever reason
then we will all or a great majority of
mankind will die because
of lack of food but very simple very
straightforward
so that's the mechanism proposed here
because that's how the animals in the
past
died according to this site why would
you think that in an age of
uh cryptocoins and digital currencies uh
becoming popular can
uh provide basic income yeah you don't
you think you are rationalizing the idea
of an
end to all humans to cope with the fact
that uh the fall of the american empire
is occurring right now and you happen to
be right smack in the middle of it
uh yeah maybe it's got
really nothing to do specifically with
the american empire okay
just when you have given up on marxism
the chinese socialists are becoming
the world's greatest superpower and you
have bet on the wrong horse by deciding
to live
in the united states well in my case uh
i don't live in the united states uh in
fact i can't go
back to the united states and you can
look me up and find out why
but um just to address this fellows uh
questions let's go one by one here okay
and so what do we have well when money
disappears whatever food there is on a
planet at that moment in time right
is a measure of how much time humans
have left as a species
crypto is just another more abstract
form of currency
okay so crypt is just one more currency
that we've invented
to do trade humans invented money when
they invented trade which was probably
some time around you know the neolithic
i would say okay
until then we live 90 percent of human
existence maybe more maybe less but
thereabouts we lived without trade trade
was not
part of our culture and chinese empire
there's never going to be
a chinese empire because first
the powers that be will not allow the
chinese to gain the upper hand either
militarily or
economically okay uh they're covering
all those bases
right now and there might be a war
because of that
there's always been wars because of
economics and that's
probably what's headed our way it's very
likely it's possible
right now the united states is much more
powerful than china
and so chinese have a lot of time a lot
of
ground to cover i don't think they'll
ever cover it i don't think they'll ever
get there
okay um there's not gonna be like it's
been in the past
you know people say well history repeats
itself it ain't gonna repeat itself this
time around
there will be no uh greek empire taking
over the persian empire the roman empire
taking over the greek empire now that's
going to happen
uh what's going to happen now in the
last phase of man
is that first the global economy is
going to collapse
before china ever makes it to becoming
the
great empire the new empire it's never
going to happen
so china uh it has wishful thinking
if they think they're going to overtake
the united states and become
a world power well i mean the number one
world power
it's never going to happen believe and
have no chance whatsoever of happening
okay uh besides you know
countries or politicians they learn from
from the past
and they take uh precautions that the
same thing doesn't occur
again okay and so uh if you thought that
one empire is going to take over the
other one
uh think again okay we're too advanced
in our understanding of history and
military and economic issues to
allow that to happen again okay i think
it's the same fellow he says
i liked a lot of these because they're
like a lot of people think out there so
it's important to look at all these
uh comments and questions this fellow
made
what makes you think that the whole
world will want to do without money when
money can be practically any type of
object are we going to
run out of objects okay it's not that
people voluntarily will say well i don't
want to use money anymore
it's that money will have no value
because we're devaluating it
every day and at some point uh
the majority or a great number of
workers will not be able to make it to
the end of the month
with the salaries that they make and so
there won't be any purpose to work
because
they can't pay their rent and buy food
and all the other regular expenses
um because they're just going to be over
their heads
with whatever salaries they get and so
we're approaching that situation where
more and more people are going to fit
into that category
that's part of the theory okay i never
understand the idea of people thinking
any modern civilization will lose social
classes governments music
or any concept that has been occurring
since the late stone age it would be
impossible to even force
let alone let it disappear on its own
yeah again
this is not an issue where uh it's going
to be imposed on people
or that people voluntarily will do uh
will
you know lose all these things or decide
not to use them
uh no it's it's going to be imposed by
mother nature
okay our global economy cannot continue
expanding forever
specifically when the um
birth rate the global birth rate uh
is falling uh the
man's artificial economy is based it's a
pyramid scheme right
and inverted pyramid scheme uh we
we expect more demand next year
companies do
and more and more and more every year
that's what companies look forward to
demand is ultimately uh population
if population is not increasing
uh especially exponentially as it has in
the past
and it's in fact turning the corner and
becoming you know
uh reaching an asymptote um
that spells trouble for the global
economy and that's where we're at right
now the
population curve is asymptotic
that's the problem okay or that's part
of the problem again
there are several more factors in there
what makes you think that we are no
different than
from any other animal when we are vastly
smarter
and the t-rex and are able to make tools
and control our birth trade assist
not really truly assist beyond our iq
limits manipulate the genes of crops
create enough food to feed billions and
these capabilities and more are getting
better every year my god but this is how
people think
they really think like this and uh so
these are
let me answer that okay here it is
yes how do we answer the spell who said
food is the only currency left when the
traditional currencies
vanish no one trades food when the only
thing of value
is food in the asphalt jungle where
there is nothing to
hunt other than another human food is
equal to survival so nobody trades that
food the only thing of value
smart intelligent resourceful humans
have no power to
uh no power or technology to do the
following we cannot travel out of the
solar system
okay alive and that's a long story i'm
not going to cover it now
uh we cannot avoid density dependent
birth rates in other words
what's that thing that's in parenthesis
next have
children again we're not going to have
children especially in the cities
city was not made for people for
children okay
so in cities that's where we all die
that's where we end our days
uh we cannot extend the life expectancy
to up 200 let alone
i i would even put the number a lot
lower than that i put 200 just to show
that you know
people think that they're going to live
forever that uh technology somehow is
going to make us
live forever something along those lines
no
it never happened and never will okay so
this
notion that uh we're gonna be uh
living to i don't know 150 years 200
years or maybe even forever
that's fantasy that's all it is it's
fantasy in the minds of people it's got
to do a lot with the
religion that we had uh for many
hundreds maybe thousands of years where
people wanted to live forever and so
they thought that after
death you still have life somehow you
know live forever your spirit
lives out there uh we cannot recover our
genetic diversity we've already lost it
and as a species
we cannot gain it again no way of doing
that again i'm not going to go into
detail there
uh we cannot live without food water or
air no matter how
uh technologically advanced we are okay
we need food water and air we are
animals i'm sorry we're not
uh plants uh we're not trees or or
flowers or or
little plants there on the ground we're
not uh
uh what is it uh we're not uh
either stones or uh sand you know we
belong to the animal world
okay so you know again you need food
water and
air those are the vitals and again we
cannot live forever as a species
either remember that all species
have a beginning and they all have an
end life does not
live forever to think that humans can
live forever because of technology or
some of these other factors this fellow
mentioned
is again a fantasy that's all it is it's
just an ideal that people have in their
minds
genetic engineering is wiping out the
genetic diversity of plants
you cannot continue to have a banana and
keep changing its genetic diversity to
such a point where it's no longer a
banana
okay so you either have a banana you
have something else
create food for billions only as long as
there is
money today money disappears
uh we don't produce food for billions
we don't produce anything at all okay so
uh this notion that oh we can produce
yeah only because of money
that's how our the human system works
okay not the ants
not the bees the humans work that way
okay
and so we have no difference from them
because in the sense
all we need is food water air you know
and that's what they need
and the only reason we have food and
water is we produce it
artificially you know in other words we
plan it we
we do something to produce it and we
only do it for money
so if money disappears there's no one
who's going to put their foot to the
shovel
okay so that's the issue here again not
voluntarily it's just the way
mother nature designed it for humans
okay
uh father here and raises another issue
was kind of funny he says uh talks about
ruminants
okay so he says man would go extinct by
being unable to sustain the most
important food source
okay what is that ruminants which
convert inedible plant matter into
nutrients
uh yeah we absolutely need the horses
and the cows right
no uh i don't think we ruminants have
anything at all to do with the survival
of humans now
uh do we need these animals to chew the
cud for us you know
you know again uh we pre we could
probably do
with without most of the animals on
earth maybe with without all of them we
don't need the animals
maybe maybe we need them for pollination
you know that sort of thing we could do
that maybe artificially and grow our own
crops
we get rid of all the weeds that we
don't need we could get rid of
certainly all the dangerous animals on
earth
we don't need sharks we don't need lions
we don't need
wolves we don't need elephants we don't
need any dangerous animal on earth we
have no
need for them whatsoever in fact we
probably would be doing them a favor
and i know a lot of animal lovers will
kill me for that uh by killing them
by murdering all the animals on earth
that are dangerous to humans
uh we don't need them they're not part
of our um
you know food pyramid we need cows we
can grow them without lions so we can we
need pigs we need uh you know chickens
we don't need them but we
we do eat them i mean that's part of our
diet today
but we don't need these other animals
dangerous animals why do we have them
just
just to make fun of them just put them
in a circus in a zoo
hunt them you know poach them what's the
purpose of having lions
and you might say well how about the
beauty well you can see it on youtube
we've already filmed lines from every
corner
of you know the world and so we know
what a lion looks like
like we know what a mastodon looks like
have you ever seen a mastodon on a real
one have you touched it have you gone to
the circus or to the zoo and seeing a
mastodon or a mammoth
no we haven't and we don't need to see
them in real life if you want to see one
while you go to museum they have all
these
you know uh films of what they look like
we've reconstructed them we can do the
same thing with lions with
bears with all these dangerous animals
that we have no
use for on earth and you another person
might say well how about the ecological
balance of blah blah
now that's uh taking it too far just
like when the masked duns disappear
humans did not
disappear neither did other animals
disappear because you know the mastodons
or the mammoths disappeared
in the same way if the lines disappear
tomorrow nothing will happen to humans
so this notion that there's going to be
an
ecological imbalance is again it's uh
it's overblown and it's uh
animal lovers and yet those same animal
lovers usually do not complain
or the other way around they complain
about insects
because they're usually not insect
lovers especially some of these
disgusting insects you know that
have weird uh you know habits
or societies or whatever and they
they're they're afraid or they don't
like these insects
uh but beautiful animals like you know
the majestic elephant
and the lion and the tiger oh we want to
conserve those
so there's a double standard there okay
so uh yeah you can beat me up but
just keep that in mind these people are
not consistent also
we have to be consistent we're gonna
allow all animals to live we gotta allow
the bacteria to live
you know that are killing us as well we
might as well let everything live
no we kill bacteria that are harmful and
in the same way we should be killing
lions and bears and wolves and other
animals that we do
not need sorry for the breaking the news
okay
anyways and i used to be an animal lover
i mean i love dogs and so on but
i mean let's be realistic we don't need
lions that's the end of truth
okay a fellow says food will go away
when money goes away okay
and that will happen because money buys
less and less yeah true
now it takes so much dollars just to
provide the basic yeah
all currency is spazzing out okay it
also seems like
temp and water lack or over abundance
storms are making some popular crops
unavailable
resources have been squandered the
population is at an impossible number
seems like we are functionally extinct
already
yeah that's uh that's pretty much it uh
it's a
good summary in in many aspects of what
i propose as well i'm saying we are
functionally
extinct we're not having children that's
one
because of density dependent birth rates
so we're not
having children anymore and so or fewer
and fewer women
are deciding to have children um
which means that you know the population
is not being replaced
there's still some countries where the
population
is expanding quite drastically still but
even countries like nigeria used to have
like seven as an average seven children
per
woman and uh or per couple and
now it's uh down to three so if you look
at some of these countries their
birth rates have dropped significantly
even in those that
traditionally are known as you know uh
countries that put out too many kids
you know those are stopping as well why
because they moved to the cities
that's why it's got nothing to do with
ngos or or the uni
united nations doing something in fact
uh recently there was an article
on china and it says that women in china
do not want to have children in fact
couples men as well
don't want to have children and so this
notion that uh
the new government or the government now
put out saying that uh well we're going
to stop this one child per family and we
can have up to two
and we're going to stop that too now we
can have up to three
women say we're not even going to have
one
and again it's because people have moved
to the cities there are economic
constraints
culture changes there are many factors
that limit
uh having children and so people are not
having children today
in the cities whenever you go to the
cities
children are out it's the transition
from the country to the cities
that kills children okay don't listen to
all these other people say well
they have all these uh organizations
that tell women especially poor women
not to have children because they can't
support them and this and that no no
it's got to do with moving from the
country to the city
once that's the globally okay so as
people move
to the cities they stop having children
irrespective of what happened in the
past their
great grandfathers their culture
whatever was in their culture in the
past when they moved to the city they
changed their culture their economics
their habits the whole works okay so
it's the transition from the country to
the city that stops
birthing that's what we
argue here in this site okay along the
same lines
a person says or asks says um
about testosterone says why is
testosterone declining is it because of
the cities or because of genetic change
um i think it's uh
and i always have uh
exchange of words with my son hans
because
he's more into the nurture and i'm more
into the nature
okay so we do not see either eye on
these issues completely
and what happens here is i believe it's
that we've exhausted our genetic
diversity that's essentially it
and at the end of a species lifetime
species lifetime right um when it's
exhausted it's genetic diversity it has
no way of regaining it
again and that's when it whittles slowly
into death
unless a mass extinction gets them right
and so
i think that what happens towards the
end is you have
uh genetically similar
individuals that have children and those
children come out wrong they come out
autistic they come out with the wrong
sexes
you know mixed sexes or whatever these
are all as far as i'm concerned these
are all
um genetically
engendered um
results okay that's what comes out of uh
mixing two people with similar genetic
code
and so yeah i think that what's
happening there uh regarding
testosterone and all these things that
we're having these days men are also
having fewer sperm counts
and so on today and i think it's all
related to genetic diversity we have
exhausted it
so whoever you marry today is
genetically from a genetic point of view
is either your sister your brother
and if you have uh sex with your sister
well you might have a
kid there you know but either that kid
or the next generation
there's gonna be problems okay and the
amish are a good example of that
in fact that was in iceland and i was
pondering about the icelanders
that maybe because you know they came
from the same stock of vikings
thousand years ago approximately okay um
you know today there's 350 000
inhabitants
in iceland they've received immigration
of course
but most of them are come from that
viking stock
a thousand a thousand hundred a 1 200
years ago
and the question is if they all or a lot
of or most of them come out of that
stock
and they've been intermarrying the
question is
you know at some point you would think
that there's going to be some problems
and so i'm wondering if iceland is
having any problem
of course they have a relatively small
population 350
000 i think in the whole island more or
less so
you know it's something that needs to be
studied just like the amish
okay uh another fellow brings up another
issue
he says let me get this thing here
uh what about the adverse effects of
race mixing
for example when caucasian meets
sub-saharan african as if humans met
with
um neanderthals just on a lower scale
i think it's a little different okay
i'll get to that in a second
sure there can be offspring but would a
human of one race
instinctively find another different at
least in nature
assuming we wouldn't live in this
urbanized world
well the first thing is we can't avoid
uh the urbanized war
world and the second thing is that
this is politics this is not science
um if you take a black man a yellow man
a white man a brown man you take any of
those
or if there are green men out there fine
take them as well
and you put them together we can have
children we can have children
a white guy like me can have children
with a black woman a yellow guy can
can have children with a brown woman and
any combination that you wish to see
there
why because we are the same species what
is race
well race uh aside from the pigmentation
and maybe other factors
is more a political issue which is what
this gentleman is
uh gentlemen i think this visitor is
raising
okay uh this is the what you got to look
at in
science okay and here we're going to
compare science against
uh you know politics this is more or
less our
genealogical tree uh you don't have to
believe in it but this is what i work
off of
more or less uh i think there's been an
evolution in humans
from way back when you know since at
least i would say
since homo habilis maybe he wasn't part
of our lineage i think
there has to be someone in two million
years ago that was part of our lineage
otherwise you know we wouldn't be here
and i think homo abilis is a good place
to start then we went to home over
erectus
and we went through uh different
intermediates in intermediate i guess
you could call them missing links
or semi-missing links we've got some
samples from intermediate periods and
we ended up where we are today but some
people say well we
mixed with the neanderthals and what we
have today is
uh some neanderthal blood from our great
grandfathers the neanderthals
well i think that's uh fantasy that's
nonsense
uh it comes from the genetic world okay
i think these two individuals the chrome
magnets or
chroma young and the um and the
neanderthals were very different species
they would not be able to breed or
inbreed right or interbreed
and have viable children and there you
can see the skulls i hope you can tell
the difference
between them you can tell me which one
is the human which one is the
neanderthal and you don't have to be an
expert believe me you look at those
calls and you know that guy is
different and you don't need to go to
college to understand that
and so i think they were radically
different in great measure because the
neanderthals
um evolved from heidelbergs who
evolved from homo erectus in uh
france england germany
spain that whole region i think was
populated close to a million years ago
maybe eight hundred thousand nine
hundred thousand years ago
uh we have the site in happisburg in
england
where apparently uh there was someone
there
a two-footed human or animal whatever
maybe it was a monkey maybe it was a
gorilla but
looks quite a bit like homo erectus and
from that fellow
eight hundred thousand nine hundred
thousand years ago
uh came to heidelberg maybe uh seven
six hundred thousand years ago from
which came the neanderthals maybe five
hundred
four hundred thousand years ago that's
more or less the the picture that i have
in my mind
here's humans they come from africa
again and that's
my version of it okay i i like that
version i think humans
uh migrated from africa met
uh europe at some point they wanted to
go into europe
i think the neanderthals killed anyone
who
crossed their border i think they they
were
locals they had the
climate in their favor they were used to
that climate they wore no clothes
uh we had to go with clothes in there
because we were cold
and we try to hunt in their territories
they probably slaughtered us
and the only time that humans were
finally able to make it across the
border maybe around 35 000 years ago
was when the neanderthals went away when
they were extinct
and that was around 40 000 years ago 5
000 years before we entered europe
that's at least what the objective
record shows
okay so the first human that we have a
skeleton has been dated to
30 uh in europe uh was dated to 35
000 years ago and the last neanderthal
according to one study
an important study by the way says that
uh the
culture the neanderthal culture
disappeared
uh sometime around forty thousand years
ago
so you reach your own conclusions uh
that's my conclusion that
we never met the neanderthals we met
them but they slaughtered us and the
only time we really
were able to get into europe was because
of um they disappeared and
so i don't think we ever made it with
them but had we met them
well it would have been kind of strange
for you know uh first communication what
do you
say or something like that to say
i want to sleep with you lady and then i
don't think the
the human if he had two eyes
he would have slept with a neanderthal
woman any more than you would have slept
with uh chimpanzee
that's more or less the way i see that i
think he would run the other way
so no i don't think we ever made it we
were very different species
and being different species means that
you cannot have viable offspring that's
my take on that
okay here's along the same lines i think
uh species
race people raise political issues
rather than scientific issues sometimes
try to tell a hotel that there is no
genetic difference between races and
they'll tell you
otherwise what is a hotel well it's a
person who's either
typically a black man okay because this
really applies to white men and yellow
men as well
okay we're all racist down deep inside
us in a way or
one way or another okay we see someone
that's green and we say well that guy's
different than me
you know that says we're all racist okay
but this is what a hotep is specifically
a person who's either
a clueless parody of afrocentricity
or loudly conspicuously and obnoxiously
pro-black
but anti-progress these are black people
who believe that
sexist responsibility politics and
gender roles are pillars of honor
and tools to overthrow racism
as such they consider gay and feminist
agendas to be
strategic attacks against the fight for
black liberation
they over indulge in conspiracy theories
about
everything from aliens to the illuminati
and
tend to lean towards fog african motives
and uh cootermans in their day-to-day
lives
a hotel is often deployed comically
in black communities especially on
social media in response to certain
eye-roll-worthy content in other words a
lot of black people make fun of their
own black
hoteps but you know a lot of what this
uh
says here that's came out of that
article by the way and
a lot of what that person says there
applies to any race we have
whites which are like that we have all
kinds of
uh all the races on earth have something
like that they have people within their
race that
think maybe their race is superior or
hates the other race
there's all kinds of mixtures out there
so that hotep applies really to any
race i just wanted to address the issue
of uh conspiracy theories and all i want
to say is that you got to choose your
conspiracy theories
um selectively you know you got to
select them
very carefully are there conspiracies
out there the answer is yes there are
conspiracy theories
and there are conspiracies by
governments especially by the u.s
government
and people say no how can a democratic
government do such
things you know this is the uh culture
of washington and jefferson they
wouldn't do those things
elected officials and these people have
a problem because
they're not in touch with the real world
at all
and here i'll give you just one example
okay just one example here
and that's uh where the united states
has admitted
in doing a false flag and that started
the vietnam wars
or essentially uh ramped it up okay
because there was a war already
but it's uh the gulf of tonkin okay and
this incident that really
you could say started the vietnam war
the original american report blamed
north vietnam for both incidents but the
pentagon papers the memoirs
of robert mcnamara and nsa publication
from 2005
suggest that the dismis that the
dismissed by department of state and
other government personnel of legitimate
concerns regarding the veracity of the
sound
of the second incident was used to
justify an
escalation by the us to a state of war
against north vietnam
okay so the united states created this
gulf of tonkin
uh incident on purpose to
to be able to have a justification to
have a war
and you say well government elected
officials did this
okay well it goes a little deeper than
that
and let me show you here okay
give me a second here because uh you're
gonna listen to
uh a murderer and that murderer
is a president or was a president of the
united states
okay and here it is give me a second
here
i'll put it on because there's with
sound okay here it goes
it says 1961 vietnam president diem's
brother shaking the hand of his murder
future u.s president lyndon johnson
november 1 1963 the dean brothers are
arrested and murdered november 23 22
days later jfk
is murdered and on august 2 and 464 a
few months later gulf of tonkin incident
starts vietnam war
they started with me on gym you remember
he was corrupt and he ought to be killed
so we killed him we all got together and
got a goddamn
bunch of thugs and we went in
assassinated
okay so uh do uh
american presidents murder people yes
they do murder people
and you say well that was the enemy and
they had to do it for political reason
for
military reason whatever that's not the
issue that's a political
the facts are the u.s presidents do kill
people
okay they started with them
we all got together
they're sent out there to do killings
okay so they kidnap people they torture
people they do all that
good stuff that you would not do uh to
your friend to your family to your
mother
right so keep that in mind to think that
u.s presidents don't do false flags and
that u.s presidents would not
murder or order the murder of someone
uh think again back then obama
said he watched the killing of they
started with me on
jim you remember he was corrupt and he
ought to be
killed so we killed him we all got
together got a goddamn
bunch of thugs and we went in the sack
okay baby say that oh i'm not going to
even factor that that it's never
happened or
never going to happen well uh you're
very naive politically maybe your
voting rights should be removed from you
okay
maybe you should relinquish them until
you learn a little more politics
okay uh here's another
issue false sense oh what are you saying
yeah they started with me on jam you
okay that's an important question very
important question
uh scientific right not politics
evolution can explain how one species
can diverge and become
two different ones that cannot
interbreed but it doesn't explain the
creation
of the original okay now i wrote that in
uh
my neanderthal book and uh here i can
only give you
these two fellows and that i mentioned
they started with me on
jam you remember he was corrupt and he
ought to be
killed so we
he was a russian who served under mr
morgan
his understudy or whatever and uh the
first guy says roll
uh uh he discovered that the the role of
chromosomes and what they play in
heredity
and the second guy he um he came up with
uh two theories i think was around the
1930s 1940s and he's a species is born
in isolation
and genetic mutation they started with
me on jam you remember
he was corrupt and he ought to be killed
we all got together
uh i came up with my own uh thought on
this and again this is
my uh graph down at the bottom not his
okay
uh the way a species is created group
branches off the mother trunk okay and
so they go into isolation they go into a
different environment
and now their mutation rate
increases it increases because they have
to fight
against the new elements they started
with me on gym
he was corrupt and he ought to be so we
killed him we all got together
bunch of thugs and we went in that's
what's
happening here and so the mutation rate
increases as the group adapts to
adapts to new diseases climates food
predators etc okay
and now after that once they become
sedentary essentially
uh all they can do is lose genetic
diversity because all they're doing is
inbreeding they do this uh
thousands and thousands of years and
what it is
is that you have all these uh
bottlenecks okay
they started with their own gym you
remember he was corrupt and he ought to
be
killed so we killed him we all got
together and got a goddamn
bunch of thugs and we went in the sack
founders effects
and and then the bottlenecks and a
sequence of
bottlenecks and founders effects is what
slowly and surely whittles our genetic
diversity
and here's a an example of that these
are
our ancestors you could say if you agree
with them
hobblies erectus and heidelberg or
in the case of um they started with me
on
jim you remember he was corrupt and he
ought to be
killed so we killed him we all got
together
so the counterpart of heidelberg in
africa was rhodesian man they found
a couple skeletons uh of this follow
but anyways here you can see that a
couple of things first that homo erectus
he lasted a lot longer than heidelberg
who lasted a lot longer than
neanderthals
and not only did they last longer but
the guy that branched out of the the
heidelberg is he
came into a new environment and from
there and as
they started with me he was corrupt and
he ought to be
killed so we killed him we all got
together and got a goddamn
bunch of of how thugs
are developed okay and it's got to do
again with dubshansky's uh
theory that genetic diver
genetic mutations and so on those are
ones
that play the crucial role isolation
and genetic uh in combination
so that's my five cents worth on that
okay
i think uh mr dum junkie was pretty they
started with
okay the neanderthal became
us okay
on your mother's side maybe we will
become whatever
type of thinking creature will exist in
the future
okay uh no again i don't think so
and i don't think the neanderthals are
us at all
okay here here i show you the
human skeletons that we found right they
started with me
remember he was corrupt and he ought to
be
they are developing a chin which
no other no other hominid has
only humans have that indentation in the
chin you can see the eyebrows are
getting smaller
you can look at the one at the bottom if
you can tell me which one is the
neanderthal which one is us
you'll see that there's a little
difference in the browse okay
uh the head structure and so on so
they started with me on jim you remember
he was corrupt and he ought to be
killed so we killed him we all got
together
the body was also very different okay uh
significantly different uh so
you know it's they had bigger bones and
so thicker bones and so on they were
like
uh weight lifters okay i'm sure they
never use clothes there were too many
differences for us to have
mated with a neanderthal so that
nonsense that the geneticist has created
that because we have two and a half or
three percent
uh genetically they started with me
remember
he was corrupt and he ought to be killed
so we killed him we all got together got
a goddamn
bunch of thugs and we went in and
assassinated give me a second here
sorry about that i didn't realize that
thanks for
warning me um
okay let me see if i say that again uh
the fellow
asked about uh how species are created
and i'm saying that
the first one is this follows that um
studied the notion
that um you know that chromosomes play
an important role
in the development of a species and in
the zhonski there he came up with a
notion
that first species develop in isolation
and
maybe he wasn't the first one to say
that but he said that
again genetic mutation plays a crucial
role
and so i developed that chart showing
that in isolation
at first a species changes its genetic
right diversity
its genetic material quickly
there's a lot of mutations and then once
it stabilizes at some point
and it becomes sedentary then they can
only lose it from then on
because all they're doing is inbreeding
unless they really mix with
you know some uh similar animal that
uh they found out there which is
unlikely
okay i think essentially you know they
they continue
losing genetic uh material until they're
all essentially clones and then after
that
they die shortly after okay and
here's another issue raised by this
fellow he says the amish
he says the ambush have guns yeah i know
they have
guns the issue is that they don't use
them to kill people but this fellow says
most of the
amish have great aim and will defend
themselves
not true not true at all in fact uh
world war one and world war ii they had
problems with them and they put a lot of
these amish in prison because they were
not willing to go to war and fight
and so this notion that this fellow has
that
you know the amish will defend
themselves is absolutely wrong never
happened never will
the amish will not kill another human
you can kill
all of them until they finally decide to
you know
they'd rather go to heaven they kill you
that's actually that's what it
comes down to okay another follow says
says the ais
artificial intelligence we do a lot of
work on that
these days okay and do you think man's
accelerated development could also be
responsible for
accelerated extinction well your
thoughts on general artificial
intelligence
um i think so i think that the fact that
um we
have you know in the last 100 years
200 years we developed so much
technology
and that was you could say exponential
and our population also expanded
exponentially
okay so both were exponential our
economics
everything expanded exponentially in
great measure because the population
expanded exponentially but then at some
point
population kept growing but we turned a
corner on technology
okay because manufacturing started dying
as as a percentage of gdp
and as a percentage of labor and today
you know it's
almost all 85 maybe is services
all kinds of services and what has
happened to um
manufacturing it's only about 15
so anything you invent today okay it's
just a modification
on an existing thing something maybe
nice to have there that's
not critical and that's not gonna put
millions of people to work and it's not
gonna
overtake services as part of our economy
so yeah i think there's been an
accelerated evolution both social
economic economic and uh in population
as well
there's a a um a tremendous evolution
that we've suffered in the last
100 years and again i think this
conduces to
you know the the final curve for man
as far as artificial intelligence yeah i
don't have much to say on that
um it does take away jobs you have all
these arms that do
a lot of mechanical work that humans
used to do they do it faster they do it
more efficiently they don't go on strike
they don't need to
you don't need to pay social security
for them or you know anything like that
they don't go on retirement
uh and you know these machines work
faster
more efficiently etc it's part of man's
progress in manufacturing
but what that does is push people into
services because there is no work or
no more labor-intensive work in
necessary in manufacturing so that's the
only thing that we have on
that i have to say about artificial
intelligence it's
it's simply not it's not in our favor
i don't even see it as something good or
bad i see it as something
that is happening we can't avoid it
because we're trying to become more
efficient and it's going to have
consequences
that's that's where i stop it just is
it is what it is that's it uh not bad
not good it's just what is
okay and yeah we are moving into a world
where we have
uh a lot more uh
automation okay in fact i just came from
a country that's got
tons of automation it's unbelievable
iceland
is the most expensive country in the
world and i don't think there i saw a
single store
where you don't do self-checkout there's
only one person manning the
the machines there everybody goes with
their phones and just buy stuff and
transfers money from
you know through the internet just
unbelievable uh iceland is very advanced
in all those things
only a country of 350 000 people but
it's very advanced
okay so uh here's some homework for
people whoever wants to tackle it okay
let's see if you can answer the question
or you do research and
try to answer this question here's a
question okay
okay i read it well it says why did
the fauna right in the seas disappear at
the same time as the animals on land
more or less you know maybe there was
some time difference but
essentially they disappeared at the same
time in the big
five mass extinctions okay because you
can see a layer in the rock that
suddenly all these animals are wiped out
there could be you know some thousands
of years maybe hundreds of thousands of
years difference there
but essentially essentially they
disappeared
geologically at the same time the
question is why
can you come up with a mechanism and
hopefully you'll consider
selectivity okay because you got to
explain cell activity how does mother
nature
spare one animal and allow another
animal to live in others will spare one
specie or set of species
orders and liquidate the others
that's you're getting you've got to
factor selectivity in there
okay folks so let's move to the lecture
today and it's got to do with whether
an electron and for that matter a quark
uh an atom are those
those do those qualify as geometric
figures i mean are we talking about
spheres balls what are we talking about
here is
is the electron a little tiny bead a
little
round bead is it because that's how we
always draw it by the way okay we draw
it
as a little point particle that goes
around you know
and so i think a good place to start is
finding out what a point particle is how
is it defined
what do we understand when we say point
particle
and it's got the word point which
obviously belongs to
geometry right the word point never been
defined but everybody uses it okay
okay so let's start with a point
particle let's find out what this is
first
okay point particle this comes out of
the um wikipedia
okay so it's an idealization of
particles heavily used in
physics i don't know about physics maybe
in mathematical physics
which ain't physics at all mathematical
physics is one thing
physics is something else okay the
difference
is mathematical physics describes and
has
ridiculous irrational physical
interpretations
physics is part of science and in
science we only allow
rational explanations okay so there's a
big difference so mathematical physics
is mostly
descriptions mathematical descriptions
and irrational explanations
nothing at all to do with science and
defining its defining feature
is that it lacks spatial extension
well if it lacks spatial extensions
looks like they're defining
nothing the word nothing right that
sounds like
that's what it sounds like to me when
you say something that doesn't have
spatial extension
you know no body zero dimensional no
radius no
diameter what are you talking about no
no length
uh no size i think that's
the definition of nothing not of
something
okay and uh so the question is whether
you can do physics with nothing are you
going to move
nothing around okay so um
says be in dimensionless it does not
take up space
again looks like they're defining space
itself which is
nothing okay a part particle
is an appropriate uh representation of
any object whenever its size shape and
structure
are irrelevant in a given context
that's got nothing to do with physics
that's got to do with math
because the person is uh or the
mathematician right is
is only trying to describe something and
he doesn't care about what the thing
really is so
it doesn't matter to him if it's a snake
a lion a shark
a bird he doesn't care because he's
going to talk about mass
force energy he's going to talk about
stuff
that has nothing to do with physics only
to do with
mathematical physics and the physics
part is too much it's just mathematics
okay he's just going to be describing
something he says i'm measured
and this is the equation that's got
nothing to do with physics physics we
have to understand the mechanism
that's what physics is about and says
far from enough uh away
any finite size object will look and
behave
as a point like object
well that's an observer uh centered or
related type description
okay because what they're saying is if
you're far enough
it looks like a little point so uh you
know the andromeda galaxy shows up as a
little point in the sky
and it's bigger than the milky way
galaxy
in the uh local uh group
the andromeda galaxy is the biggest
galaxy
and to our eye it looks like a little
dot in the sky if you can see it
on a good day so the question is uh
are we gonna look at what the observer
perceived
or are we going to analyze what the
andromeda galaxy
is in fact a bunch of stars
gazillions of them you know rolling
around the center
that's a little different than saying
well it's just a dot in the sky
so these people are going to talk about
the dot in the sky and how much mass
that
dot in the sky has and that's good in
math maybe but it's not good at all in
physics and physics we have to deal with
what the andromeda galaxy is in reality
if we're going to explain a mechanism
for example how it spins what what its
magnetic field looks like or
or does or whatever that's what we're
interested in physics
not in saying well it has so much mass
and it pulls
uh gravitationally on the
milky way galaxy with such and such
force and such and such energy
what is that it's just a description and
again observer related
in the theory of gravity physicists not
physicists but mathematicians
mathematicians as we call them uh often
discuss
a point mass yeah we don't care about
point masses meaning a point particle
with a non-zero mass and no other
properties or structure
well we got a problem there because if
it's uh
it's a point mass and it's got mass
and they're saying it's got no size it's
actually nothing there
well how can nothing have mass and i
thought mass
the definition of mass was uh you know
that it's a
quantity of matter or or a measure of
quantity of matter
these people say it doesn't have any
matter because they don't care
about the object itself they don't care
about the body
they're not going to be dealing with the
body because they have no purpose for a
body they can't put a body
in an equation so what are they going to
put in there well it's weight it's mass
it's length
okay whatever they're gonna put a number
in there with it with a uh
unit and so they're they don't care
about what the thing itself looks like
and that's gonna haunt them in both
relativity as well as quantum mechanics
not to mention string theory which is
also a mathematical theory by the way
not even a theory it's just a
description theories are
explanations explanations or theories
in quantum mechanics and elementary
particle also called point particles
such as an electron quark or photon
is a particle with what no internal
structure
the size of an elementary particle is
exactly
zero okay so here we're dealing with
physics
physics first and foremost requires an
object you can't do physics without an
object what is there to see what is
there to
measure what is there to experiment in
the lab if you consider
experiments part of science what are we
going to do with a zero dimensional
nothing
so no that's not true for physics in
physics we need an
object that's the first rule of physics
these people are doing physics
without objects that's the problem okay
and you know we have a little bit of
problem with that when people start
doing physics without something without
a thing in front of you
okay so what the mathematicians have
invented
okay is this thing called infinitesimal
infinitesimal and what is infinitesimal
well as you can see it's a mathematical
notion
okay and they apply it to size as well
the farther you go the smaller andromeda
gets
the farther you go the ant gets smaller
and so on down the line you know
you want to see your pen look like a
little dot no problem just put it out in
the
horizon in the distance and your pen
will look
infinitesimally okay infinitesimal
so it says infinite decimals or
infinitesimal numbers
right were you talking about math right
quantif quantities that are closer to
zero than
any other standard real number but are
not zero
so they have this notion where something
approaching zero
in any sense could be in the zero size
zero mass zero
length zero the radius as it approaches
zero
they say well that's infinitesimal
the problem with the word infinitesimal
is they use it as a synonym of zero
whenever it's convenient so when you
wanna say
zero sometimes in math well you say well
it's infinitesimal it's getting
infinitesimally
smaller okay and again that's an
observer
related issue it's like i can't see the
atom
so it's infinitesimally small
okay that's how they they
deal with it but then they say what's a
point particle oh what's a point
particle
it's one that has no size so now we went
from infinite testimony we equated it
to zero size you see how this is
how the language is used in mathematics
mathematics in mathematical physics
they equate infinitesimal many times
with zero
and they give you the idea that well
that's an infinitesimal particle
and you say okay i understand that's a
very small particle but then they jump
the river and they go on the other side
and they say well it's a point particle
oh what's a point particle
is it an infinitesimally small particle
now it's a zero size particle no
volume no nothing except mass charge and
all the other good stuff
okay because the body is not important
for
a mathematician okay and there's another
version incalculably exceedingly and
immeasurably minute vanishingly
small okay so those are the notions
people have with this
strange word called infinitesimal
and parallel to that i mean where did
they get all this stuff or how are they
using this well here
here you see uh how calculus developed
essentially okay and it has to do with
this notion of the limit
okay uh that they've created in
mathematics it's uh you could say it's
the foundation of calculus
it's the the value that a function
approaches as the
input approaches some value okay and so
as um x approaches zero what
happens to f of x the function of x
that's essentially
what it's all about and this is what
they turn into this
infinitesimal thing okay because they're
not concerned again about structure or
body or
things they're just concerned about
doing calculations
and that's how particles became
infinitesimally small meaning point
particles meaning
zero size okay so uh what
what particles do we have well we have
these electrons
and they are point particles they're
considered to be point particles in
other words zero size
why because they're not going to take
the size or the
or the diameter or the radius of the
uh electron into consideration or it's
or if it's got
constituents something smaller than that
that
comprises the electron okay
uh and that's not the only one you have
the gluons you have the
quarks they're all point particles
they're all zero sized particles
why because they can't see them and so
they say well they're there we don't
know their size we don't know their
diameter we don't know what they're made
out of
and they just call those point particles
or elementary particles or
fundamental particles these are the
words that they use
whatever you're referring to
infinitesimal particle meaning
zero size particles whenever it's
convenient whenever it's
useful okay so this is how the language
is gonna be treated
if you're not careful you may be hearing
one thing understanding another
okay so here's a there's an infinite
small particle i mean you know how they
determine these things sometimes is
uh for example a specific case
uh rutherford ernst rutherford he went
in there
and he shot uh particles at
uh what he thought was a gold well a
gold foil which he thought
was primarily you know full of holes or
whatever but there was
obviously material he expected some of
these particles to go through something
bounce back
but you know some of them hit right in
the center and bounce back
and so he says oh there's something in
that center of where this
particle hit and he figured out that way
that
and atom is mostly empty space because
most of them went through
but some of them bounced against the
proton which was allegedly in the center
or
against some nucleus in there uh
comprised of uh
protons and neutrons and the particle
bounce back okay it's that back
scattering experiment
well here's here's a case that i can
show you okay
here's a spider's web and the spider's
in the center
and you take some tiny very tiny pebbles
and you throw it
at the spider and spider web
well if you throw it through the holes
you know between the
the little web there uh the particle
goes through
and uh when you throw it at the center
you'll probably hit the
spider and the particle bounces back
your little
uh grain of sand or whatever you through
and it bounces back
so does that show that
um the web does not exist there that
it's mostly empty space because most of
the grains went through
the holes they could even rip some of
those little uh
connections there because maybe they're
not strong enough to
withstand a pebble and so it goes
through and you say okay they all went
through
except when i hit it in the center and
then it bounced back
does that prove that the
proton the center of the uh of this web
is a solid particle or does it prove
maybe or could it be interpreted as
being a
web okay that um
and and we just managed to hit the
center and when it hits the center it
bounces
out back to you and when it doesn't hit
the center it goes through
so is the atom like that maybe maybe
it's not
all empty space as mr rutherford
concluded
and what if it's like this
okay here we have a uh the 3d version
okay 3d version of a spider's web okay
all over the place and so you shoot a
particle and it turns out it goes
through most of those holes but when you
shoot in
closer to the center well it bounces
back now
if the atom looks like that
did you figure out that an atom is just
a little dot in the center and a lot of
another one rolling around which is what
the planetary model says
what if an atom looks like that somehow
like that somewhat like that
so again this uh notion that perhaps
uh we have a little tiny bead called the
electron rolling around somewhere
in the what is known as the uh energy
levels
of an atom you know the orbitals
uh and at the center you have
the proton ball and then in between you
have
absolutely nothing which is the
planetary model even to this day that's
the one they use for electricity for
ionization for quantum jumping
uh maybe they've got the wrong model
maybe the model has to be looked at
again
revised okay
here's the proton today and
let's go with that first okay and the
proton is made of these
uh three quarks but it turns out that
the quarks
are point particles according to the
standard model if you look it up you'll
find out
that the quarks are point particle
meaning
no size and by the way
they're held together by these bed
springs
i call them bed springs and they're
known as gluons they're these
uh strong for they mediate the strong
force and those bed string
springs are also regarded or considered
or taken to be
uh zero dimensional in other words
they're point particles so we have this
uh proton and it's made of three quarks
point particles nothing there which are
held together
by bed springs which are point particles
which is nothing there
that sounds like the proton is
absolutely nothing
and yet the proton is said to have a
diameter a radius
and it's made out of these three
nothings which are held together by
three
by lots of nothings bunch important
particles everywhere
does that make any sense because that's
what quan that's the official version of
quantum
physical interpretation they have no
idea what a quark looks like or what a
glue on bed spring looks like okay
they treat them as point particles
except when they have to draw them to
mislead you to
think that they've got the right
physical interpretation for
what happens inside a proton or a
neutron for that matter because they're
also made of three quarks
and here's uh the uh proton in action
okay that's what it looks like so they
have these zero dimensional bed springs
holding together three dimen
zero dimensional quarks and although
this
zero dimensional nothingness is what the
proton
is or made of or whatever so you figure
out what a proton is
and that's the proton which is the big
guy let's look at the electron now
because that's the one we're going to be
analyzing
here's a swedish electron okay
uh you say swedish bill yeah swedish
university proved
filmed the electron in motion
here it is okay oh fell on the other
side hold on give me a second
ah there you go
i lost it completely oh here it is
give me a second here there he goes okay
here's the swedish electron okay that's
what they filmed
this is a real film okay that they claim
to have
made what do they film if the electron
is a point particle zero dimensional no
volume
thingy that's got mass no structure
no uh body they filmed it
and then they say it's uh what is an
elementary particle is one that is not
made of smaller parts
fundamental particle is not made of
anything they cannot figure out what
it's made out of so they say it's not
made of anything it's like
the buck stops here you know this is the
particle that makes up everything else
so so to speak
and there you see all these little lines
like if it were
made of little pieces this electron
has different layers it looks like
nested layers
what does it look like to you they say
they film the electron how could they
film the electron if it's zero
dimensional
how can that be the electron if it's a
fundamental elementary particle which
means it's not made of anything when
this one is made
of obviously patently
made of all these nested whatevers
whatever those are okay so this is
this is the issue these people just
print that and people
buy it like candy you know they say oh
okay they proved that they
in sweden sweden they should get a noble
and so on down the line
what are we staring at is that an
electron what is that
how can they film an electron and they
say well we did because we had these
uh fast uh cameras etc etc etc
and then they defined the electron as a
zero dimensional
point particle aside from the fact aside
from the fact
that you know uh the electron moves
around
the proton right in the hydrogen atom
and okay let's concede that then why
doesn't that electron fly away doesn't
it
why does it fall to the nucleus what
keeps it bound around the proton that's
the issue
okay so all these issues have never been
answered
and they never will be because you know
the model is screwed up
okay so here is uh the model they show
you they show you something like that
you get the three
quarks in the center forming the proton
okay and you have the electron blue one
there going around
as you can see it's going from energy
level to energy level from uh
orbital to orbital okay as it falls it
releases energy that's that green arrow
going out there
and when energy comes in it pushes the
electron to
a higher level or higher orbital that's
the model
that that's the official model and you
say okay so
is that the uh that's the model with
which we operate
well the the problem is that if all
these are zero dimensional
this is what the model looks like and
i'm being kind with a proton because
there should be a proton there if it's
made out of zero dimensional particles
and the electron you know i don't know
where that went because it's zero
dimensional we have a zero dimensional
nothing
orbiting at different orbitals which are
concepts
a uh particle in the center which is
made of nothing
we have three nothings known as quarks
and they're uh held together by three
nothings or many nothings known as
gluons
that's the quantum atom
that's the official quantum atom okay so
what should we conclude well
is the electron a uh geometric figure
does it qualify as a
i don't know a sphere a circle maybe a
cube
i don't know i mean let's find out these
are the conclusions
okay the quantum electron
does not qualify as a geometric figure
okay under any definition okay we have
the euclidean definition
he definitely figures that which has a
boundary and boundary is that which is
the
border of a figure so he had a circular
definition but
uh electron doesn't fit either of those
two descriptions
okay the electron falls
fails the c touch definition of figure
of mathematical physics
that's the one mathematical physics
operates by that's the one they
use that an object is that which you can
see or touch
you can't see the electron you can't
touch it especially a zero dimensional
one so it fails
that definition as well the electron
fails the shape definition of science
and physics which is that which i shape
something that has zero dimensions and
not a something
okay no volume that's not a something it
has to have volume
it has to have a shape it's got to be
something
there otherwise it's not an object and
if it's not an object it doesn't belong
in physics
maybe in math i don't know i don't know
what they do over there but that doesn't
belong in physics or science
and then um the electron is specifically
defined and described as a zero
dimensional point or elementary or
fundamental particle
okay so that's the electron that's the
formal definition of that
and so if or description so if that's
the description
of an electron you know again what are
we talking about we're talking about
nothing
and so the conclusion is the electron is
a non-entity
let alone a figure it's nothing
so far we have nothing in front of us
okay
and so let me show you the electron
famous electron see what it looks like
the the one from quantum okay
i'm going to show you the quantum
electron here it is
and get it up here that's what the
electron looks like
right underneath the arrow okay so if
that's a geometric figure
as far as you're concerned well then you
do have it you
you know you have the electron is a a
thing it's a figure
okay but if you see nothing underneath
there well then the electron is
absolutely nothing
by definition and by description
and also you know the way they use it
because they don't care about
bodies anymore they just care about what
number
they're going to put in an equation okay
okay let's move on to questions that
people made and comments uh
here's the first one has to do with
black holes remember we
stopped with black holes the other day
that's what we analyzed whether a black
hole
is a geometric figure okay so fellow
raises
this question says the simplest static
black hole have mass
but neither electric charge or angular
momentum okay i think he got this out of
the quick
wikipedia because it says something's
very similar these black holes are often
referred to as squash
black holes some black holes are very
tiny but have mass of large
of a large mountain another kind of
black hole is called the stellar
okay there are many many stellar black
holes super
massive black holes exist in the center
of most galaxies again all this is
taken directly out of the um what is it
out of the
mainstream okay this is what everybody
puts in our blogs and their articles and
it's just pasted on here that's
essentially what it is
they are astonishingly heavy with masses
ranging millions of millions
to billions of solar mass a typical
stellar blah blah blah blah blah
okay that's not the question let's
answer the question that this
fellow has to address this is the only
issue
a fellow has to address and that's the
one mr hawking raised okay
and here it is this is the formal this
is the official version
okay this is the party line and i'm just
going to read that
part down there in the center infinite
density
eddie and thought it was simply not
possible that a star would collapse to a
point
einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not shrink
to what
zero size and chandrasekhar won the
nobel prize for proving mathematically
that a black hole collapses to zero size
so the question is not all these other
things where they say well these are all
the different kinds of
uh black holes that are out there the
stellar one the small ones the big ones
no no we want to know what a black hole
looks like and if a black hole looks
like zero dimensional zero size zero
nothing
all we have in front of us is nothing
absolutely nothing
that's the issue that you gotta address
another fella says i like this one
made me hungry okay well it says uh
that uh black hole looks like a donut
says the black holes don't uh isn't a
hole it is a donut see we have all these
notions out there people have
one guy thinks it's a ball the other guy
thinks it's uh
tiny infinite testimony this other guy
thinks it's a donut and so
we have all these weird notions after
where these people get these things
who knows they just read one guy reads
over here the other guy reads over there
and they all get it wrong
okay it is a taurus viewed from the side
where you can see through the middle
there are no black holes so looking at a
doughnut we don't say oh look a zero
dimensional donut hole
now we say oh look a donut but that is
insane upside down world we live in
today well yeah
obviously you know because we need to
figure out if a black hole looks like
that like a donut or the whole of the
donut or
or like nothing like zero dimensional
nothing because
mr um chandrasekhar said it collapses to
a point meaning to zero because that's
what his calculation showed
okay so uh what does a zero dimensional
entity look like that's what we want to
find out
okay now they follow along the same
lines also with black holes
there's a black hole day okay and
questions for black holes comments
paul says at the center of the taurus we
have extreme amount of mass
it simply isn't nothing okay then what
is it how would nothingness attract
what is around it yeah how would it
that's what i want to know
how do you how does nothing attract
anything around it
so don't ask the question answer the
question
you got to answer the question because
these people are saying it's nothing
and you're asking a question like saying
it's got to be something because you're
wrong bill because
otherwise it wouldn't attract anything
around it but these people say not me
these people are saying that's nothing
it's a
zero dimensional zero volume infinite
density
so the question is how does nothing
which is what i just described pull on
anything
how do you produce gravity with nothing
that's the question
that you have to answer if you're gonna
vouch for the black hole because
a black hole is defined described
and uh taken to be nothing okay
and so here we have uh my great turtle
uh thing here's the turtle rotating
around mass what is mass
well mass is a concept okay and here you
have the uh
famous space-time uh sheet
and of course uh there is no such
monster as space time so the
turtle is really going around nothing
and if you remove the mask because
there's no object in the center
well what the hell is the turtle going
around what is pulling on the
turtle so that's the question people
have to answer
okay yes black hole is defined
as nothing and until you get your
brain around that that that's what the
mathematicians are saying
that a black hole collapses to zero
volume there is nothing there there is
no body
crushes all matter out of existence per
their own words their own descriptions
what do we have left we have only mass
what is mass a concept it's like saying
the elephant's not there but the weight
of the elephant is still you know
ghosting around it's
still a phantom that's what these people
are saying
is that physics yeah
and um one vowel
tries to define nothing in in that same
context okay he says
uh he says uh nothing to me just means
that which cannot be measured or seen
uh no that's not the definition of
nothing for two reasons one you're
introducing an observer
you never define words using observers
okay
not scientific words you can define time
like that time is not a scientific word
we don't care about time that's
something that concerns only the
mathematicians
and then you need an observer but to
define all these other words
such as nothing no you don't need an
observer you need to figure out what
nothing is
in the absence of an observer and so
nothing that which
does not have shape which lacks shape
okay that's the definition of nothing
so uh a black hole is nothing because
it's that which doesn't have shape okay
another fellow says that a black hole
really looks not like a donut it looks
more like a drain
hello all these notions that people have
about black holes
perhaps the black hole is a drain hole
uh-huh well the drain into what
because a hole has to be in something
that
is physical something that has shape
then you can put a hole in it but if you
have absolutely nothing you want to make
a hole in nothing well i don't know
it doesn't even work in golf okay uh
a sink drains hole that is open and the
water drains out
black hole is of the same nature objects
are escaping and draining into okay
in a black hole what is the object
draining into your guess is as good as
mine
yeah i know because people don't
question these things these are coming
from
uh harvard and uh what is it cambridge
cambridge and uh people don't question
these people say well no no because all
these mathematicians they can't all be
wrong
what is a black hole please ask them to
draw it
don't tell me you know how much mass it
has who cares about that
i want to know what it looks like that's
that's got to do with physics
but to say that it's big that's uh
that it's uh event horizon is so so
uh it's got so much radius or or
diameter
and that things fall in at such and such
rate at the such and such velocity who
cares about all that
i want to know what a black hole looks
like before you begin your presentation
and we need to know what it looks like
and if you tell me it's zero dimensional
you have not defined
defined or described the black hole
you've defined
nothing the word nothing that's what you
did
okay phil says
okay so everything that takes up space
and has mass
is matter but a black hole
crushes all matter out of existence
okay all matter is made up of atoms yeah
which are in turn made up of protons and
returns an electron
yeah we agree the more atoms per volume
the higher the density of the mass
okay at the center of the largest black
hole recites the highest density of mass
density of mass what are you talking
about if mass relies on matter and
and the black hole crushes all matter
out of existence
what mass do you possibly can you
possibly have
so where is this mask coming from i mean
is it a ghost that god sends and says
i'm gonna give a million kilograms for
that mass
in the center over there in the middle
of the nowhere so
what is what is occupying that space if
a black hole is zero dimensional zero
diameter zero nothing okay they
certainly are
absolutely nothing in zero dimension
without shape
how would that attract what's around
them again same issue you know
and so you know i'd like to put this out
uh give me a second here
gotta get them all the way from the
bottom here okay
and here's the first answer okay this
comes from
david harrison he's a physicist
mathematical physicist mathematician
and he talks about he wrote a paper or
an article
called black holes university of toronto
and
if the mass of star is greater than
about three solar masses
it goes through the neutron star stage
and keeps collapsing in this case
the gravitational attraction is so
intense the neutrons are literally
what crushed out of existence
no more neutrons their structure is gone
we call that object a black hole
i characterize a black hole as an object
whose gravitational pressure is so
intense that the matter of the object is
what
crushed out of existence the matter is
crushed out of existence there are no
protons no neutrons no
electrons no atoms no nothing they're
crushed
out of existence so what's left
a ghost a soul you killed the body and
the soul goes to heaven is that what
this is about
is this some religious stuff we can
calculate the schwa
radius for the mass of the earth it
works out to be about one-third of an
inch
what this means is if if we could
compact the uh
earth so that its radius gets down to
one third of an inch the gravitational
attraction becomes so strong enough
that earth gets crushed out of existence
creating a black hole
it's always crushed out of existence
crushed out of existence
there is no matter in a black hole
so uh you know we end up with uh
my uh what i call the circular argument
of black holes
okay here it is
there's a circular argument okay so that
you memorize it
black hole of mathematics you start out
with a black hole it's only mass
but it turns out mass is the quantity of
matter requires atoms
etcetera etcetera but a black hole
crushes all matter out of existence
so what do we have well black hole is
only mass
and what is mass it's a concept invented
by the mathematicians it's a number
it's a value it's got no place in
science
okay in science we have to figure out
what the
object looks like we can't do physics
without objects you need a thing
to be to do physics without thing you
don't have physics at all
okay um another issue
another question person asks is uh
because something is in motion doesn't
rule it out as an object
well no of course not your body is in
motion did your body suddenly disappear
into the concept zone as you move
no it's in reverse see you've got to
have an object
before you can talk about motion but now
you're not talking about
objects you're talking about motion okay
the subject matter is motion not object
and just because it moved it didn't
become a concept because what's
the concept is motion not not the object
now you're talking about different
subjects suddenly you've drifted into
the
subject called motion and motion is a
concept
okay so we're not talking about an
object object stand still
you point to it and you identify and you
say that's an object okay we're done
now you can talk about motion weight
measurement whatever you want to talk
about
but first you got to identify the object
before you move
anything okay so it's not that uh the
object becomes a concept because it
moved motion
is the concept not object okay
should not be confused uh in which part
of the
dissertation you're at okay
now here's another issue well it says
a cube is comprised of 12 line segments
six squares is that a cube there those
six
squares there is that a cue
12 lines and it turns out that
you know if if that's what a cube is 12
line
segments right not lines but line
segments
or six squares and the square is
hollow there's nothing there's a square
is just four lines there's nothing in
that window there's no
window pane no glass okay then what you
have when you build your famous cube is
a hollow
not a solid that's not a solid that's a
hollow
that's what a cube is and it turns out
it's even worse than that because those
lines are made of points
what is a point is a point a little dot
is it a
geometric figure no point is a location
so we have a bunch of locations forming
the so-called lines that form the
squares that form the cube
all we have is a bunch of a big
itinerary
a squarish or cubic itinerary oh
it was a perimeter that is so if that's
what a cube is it doesn't belong in
geometry
geometry begins with shapes you need to
have a thing
there and those aren't shapes those are
itineraries their location a bunch of
locations that's all we have there
okay another fella
brings up an issue he says
you can't explain with you cannot right
you can't
explain without describing um
yes you can you don't need to describe
and
for that you need to define what explain
and describe mean you need to define
these terms in physics
in science right you need to define
these terms you can't just
say whatever it comes out of your top of
your head okay and so explain
uh what is it uh it's the theorize
essentially
the causes or reasons in case of
philosophy underlying a phenomenon
and a second version of that would be
how
in physics a consummated event happened
as an explanation deals exclusively with
the past
you only explain consummated events
what's described was description a
listing of properties of a physical
object okay science adjectives describe
objects and adverbs
qualify or characterize motion
so first we have to find out the
difference between
explanation and and description
okay and so uh let's see what we have in
science do we need to
describe in order to explain well not
really here you have the scientific
method
okay science is rational explanation the
scientific
method requires that you have the
objects the definitions
and the initial scene the first frames
of your film that on which you're going
to base your theory your explanation
nowhere do you see a provision for
description
you need objects and definitions okay
now the initial scene yeah you can
describe if you want the initial scene
but that's not the theory
okay uh we call that an assumption
not not a description really what we're
focusing is
on the meaning of what we're presenting
as our first phrase the initial scene
okay and then comes the theory which is
uh the mechanism
and the causes of you know what what
caused the event to happen
so no uh first you need to differentiate
between description and explanation
and no one has ever done that you know
we have to do that in
rational science explanation and
descriptions are not synonyms
okay another fellow asks lots of
questions because you know it took a
long time
to answer them so we collected them and
here it is
says you say mathematical physics is
irrational
yeah the physical interpretations of
mathematical physics okay
is mathematics without physics rational
i would say that it should be logical
okay the illogical the irrationality
comes when
you try to merge math with physics
mathematical physics
that's an irrationality math is math
physics is physics never between shall
mean
uh you you math describes
and as long as you describe and you use
an equation you want to do measurements
that's fine keep it in that realm don't
mix it with physics physics is something
else
physics you have to explain something
and
mathematical physics becomes an
irrationality because
they're using the descriptions the
mathematical descriptions
to reach conclusions about how the
universe works
how mother nature does their stuff
that's where we have a problem
because you cannot extrapolate whatever
descriptions you have
in mathematics and turn them into
explanations
in physics and at the end of let's say
to top it out the icing on the cake say
well we didn't understand any of that
anyways but let's continue rolling
no that's not physique that's not
science that is irrationality that's
poppycock
that's what it is no math is math and
physics is physics you got to keep them
apart
math is a logical language but it's a
language that is very
limited okay the
the language of mathematics is only used
to describe
quantitatively chinese
greek english spanish russian
any language you can think of out there
they have the ability to describe and
explain qualitatively
something that mathematics cannot do
whatsoever never will
never can okay it's impossible
you cannot use the language of math to
explain how this universe works the
causes the mechanisms
for that you need a superior language
which is chinese
greek english russian any of those
languages that you can think of you can
even use
icelandic which is in under you can't
understand that viking language
at all yeah you you can use any language
to
talk qualitatively you can't use math to
talk qualitatively
and that's what math fizz mathematical
physics
attempts to do to explain things about
the real world
extrapolating notions from mathematics
such as
force mass energy which have nothing to
do with the qualitative world
it only has to do with a quantitative
world okay so
that's that's where you gotta draw the
line so yeah do not confuse math
with math fizz okay those are two
different
things it's math phys which is
irrational mathematics
is a logical language you know
it's all it is uh quantitative only
purpose
is quantitative okay a fellow complains
about dimensions he says
i was reading and came across this
biotic diversity is huge complex and
multi-dimensional
yeah and these dimensions
include kinds of organisms numbers of
organisms how organisms are distributed
et cetera et cetera
you can really tell from this man's
writing just how they treat dimensions
as
number lines all four items on that list
are number lines
yeah he's right uh you know they talk
about infinite dimensions what do you
mean infinite dimension what does that
mean
well it means that could be the
dimension of temperature of mass of
whatever you can put anything you want
there it's like
any measurement falls on a dimension
under this notion because it's a
what is it um number line that's what it
is
and so you can use a number line for
example for temperature
and you can put little check marks there
little marks
and put numbers underneath them and talk
about you know the units
you know centigrade or fahrenheit or
whatever you want
what are you talking about are you
talking about a dimension length width
and height you know how things
point or or whether they are orthogonal
to each other no you're talking about a
number line which has no
direction whatsoever it only has
magnitude
and that is what is called the number
line and
what these people have done is they've
taken these number lines and called them
dimensions coordinates and vectors
they use the words of physics to apply
them to the number lines
otherwise they wouldn't be able to tell
you that uh space time is four
dimensional they would have to say
well um space time is four four number
line
you say what did you say what do you
mean four number line what does that
mean
but if you say four dimensional say oh
okay i see and i can see why i can't
understand them or i can't
well i can't see them uh this space time
because it's four dimensional that's
beyond my capability i can only see
three dimensional
now if they called it four number line
people would say what the hell is that
a four number lined object that's how
you would get them
so you got to make sure that you
understand that these people are talking
about number lines and not dimensions
but they use the word dimensions and
people think they're talking about a
four-dimensional
unimaginable object obviously because no
one can imagine four-dimensional object
and they say what's beyond our
capability like for a flat earth
thursday would be to
imagine our three-dimensional solid
world
that's that's the analogy they use to
drive it through
your head yeah they're they're using the
word dimension when they should be
talking about number lines that's what
they are they don't have dimensions in
physics
in mathematical physics okay another
fellow says
why magnetic thread not clash against
electromagnetic rope around the magnet
when
magnetic threads spin well again the big
problem here is that people are talking
about see
and touch they think that
uh an object is that which you can see
or touch and so they say how come these
do things don't touch
in this case right each other meaning
you know they go through each other but
that's not the point of the point is
they don't even touch
so they say how come they don't touch
well they don't touch because the
definition of the word object has
nothing to do with the word touch
or with the word see the definition of
the word object is that which has
shape the thread the rope have shape
period we're done they're objects they
don't have the property of touch
and certainly we cannot see them we
cannot see atoms these are
orders of magnitude thinner smaller
whatever
so you cannot see or touch them okay so
don't bring in touch or see into the
conversation
whenever you do you're you're thinking
in
ordinary everyday terms where you see
and touch
things and yet still in that case you
can't see
the air does that mean the air is not a
physical object because you cannot see
it
so again you gotta see and touch are the
problem people
confuse the word object with the word
see and touch
where the words see and touch they think
that object that
you can see your touch and that is not
the definition of
object and that's what where people get
confused
yeah you got to define these terms
scientifically in order to use them
consistently in a dissertation
okay another issue fella says
an alternative explanation for compton's
effect
okay uh compton's effect uh let's show
you here
maybe a picture's worth a thousand words
okay
and here's the version of quantum
mechanics
versus the version of the rope model
okay so here it goes okay
uh the one on the left quantum mechanic
one on the right uh hypothesis and you
can see
uh in quantum mechanics what they have
is these balls
they could be also waves and they come
in they hit an atom
and what comes out on the other side is
either
is on one hand you have current and on
the other one you have light
the red balls coming out of there are
current
and that's because the incoming beam
hit an electron and forced it
out of its uh its shell okay so this
electron is now flying
and many of them form uh a current
all these are electrons are moving from
atom to atom
okay and that's your current what
happens on the other side well you have
light
and what's happened to light is the um
wavelength gets uh longer meaning
frequency changes okay
what is the rope model well what you
have is a rope again
that's light there's no balls or waves
coming in
what you have is a torquing rope because
the rope
torques it compels the uh
electron but really the atoms that form
the material that you're hitting against
which is
polished metal okay it forces the atoms
to spin
in a given direction and aligns them
and that's what forms current because
all these um
electron shells are merged and they're
spinning they're spinning either
clockwise or counterclockwise depending
on how the signal came in
and that's what's going in one direction
that's what we're going to call current
what happens in another direction is
what we call light which is
a longer wavelength shorter frequency
light okay electromagnetic phenomena
because uh the the
electron shells that uh to which the
first beam came
onto uh made it go slower in other words
the the signal moving along
the rope uh going downwards there light
uh the signal is now lower why because
the
frequency has been it has lowered and
what's
increased is the wavelength okay so the
the effect is the same thing as in
quantum mechanics
except that the model for electricity
and the model for
light coming out of the uh
collision we can call it collision uh is
different
their their notion of what current is a
bunch of little particles coming
out of the uh metal polished metal ours
is that
the particles are still there the atoms
are still there they're just
merged and spinning that's what's
happening
and light obviously loses uh frequency
because it hits something okay the
incoming light has
higher frequency than the outgoing light
and in the case of
the rope model all we have is longer
wavelength
of longer link length really of the rope
that's it so these are the two models
these are the two mechanisms
for you to ponder okay and again the
problem with
uh atom that the quantum mechanics has
there is we don't know why those little
red balls known as electrons don't fly
out spontaneously
from the atom okay
and i think we have one more question
here
or comment yeah i like this one
we'll end the day with this uh fella
says uh
he says i'm sad that bill no longer
replies to comments those were the good
old days
uh i do reply to comments i don't reply
to comments uh directly
on youtube partly because a lot of
people erase they come in they do a hit
and run
so they put comments you answer and then
they vanish and they leave you talking
to the wall
that's happened to me so many times and
one of the reasons
uh i stopped answering comments and then
i do answer comments here so all you got
to do is watch the next video and you'll
probably see your comment being
addressed here
okay and so we'll see you on wednesday
and i'm going to
be here with ons and we're going to do
our monthly review of the previous month
okay so if you have any questions
comments we're going to
address some real time on wednesday
we'll see you there